Train your puppy to sleep through the night and you might finally get a full night's rest, too.
You will need a feeding schedule, exercise, a puppy bed or a crate, and a hot water bottle or heating pad.
Step one: Get your puppy on a regular feeding schedule and follow it strictly...
...so you'll know when your puppy needs to take care of his business.
Don't give your puppy food or water later in the evening.
Set a cutoff time of seven pm.
Step two: Give your puppy plenty of exercise during the day.
Go for a walk after work or play fetch in the yard.
Wind things down with a more gentle activity like brushing or petting close to bedtime.
Step three: Take the puppy outside right before bedtime even if they don't have to go.
They'll eventually learn what's expected of them.
Step four: Set up a bed or crate in your bedroom, preferably next to your bed.
The puppy will take sleeping cues from you when it's time for lights out.
If the puppy must sleep in another room, put a white noise machine or ticking clock nearby to soothe them.
Step five: Expect that the puppy won't be able to make it through the night for a while.
If they cry, go out for a potty break immediately and then return the puppy directly to bed.
Eventually, they'll be able to hold it longer.
Don't play with them or they'll wake you up each time they want to get frisky.
Step six: Make a new puppy feel more at home by placing a hot water bottle or heating pad...
...under a blanket in their sleeping area to imitate their litter mates.
Soon, both the puppy and you will sleep like a baby.
Did you know? Dalmatian puppies are born with a pure white coat.
Their spots develop as they mature.